[Applause]
all right guys next one 15 Renegade
it's a push
new key
new key part number
and uh we're already on our way
don't think that this is a gateway car
we're gonna find out though
[Music]
Sparky
ignition off
Hazard Zone
that's quick and easy
I had somebody comment what happened
God I had somebody comment and say that
um
the password
the tool pulled
like didn't enter in it enter it
properly or it was wrong I don't know
let's do this do you remember the number
oh probably won't have the car on
so I am curious what that is we'll check
interesting
that it lists it as active
stored
don't care
say that that's interesting that there's
a little red mark next to it I mean it's
not communicating this car is running
fine so
let's just uh move ahead
ignition off
flashers on
smart key on the stock start stop button
make sure things
now are we assuming that they're talking
about the new smart key
tough one uh
we're gonna go with yes
they want the new one
yes
smart key on the start stop button make
sure
press release unlock button so that's
what I'm doing
continuously pressing
unlock
that angle
and we just heard
the door lock cycle
running successful I'm gonna learn
another one nope
a little Escape out of here
and uh customer key
works fine new key
works fine and as always after I shut
this off I'll test both individually
it's a unique one it's a sip 22
emergency key I've already got a video
on that I'll link it and that's it we're
done